the CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is a former
CIA deputy director and acting director
Michael good morning morning these
pictures we've seen overnight so rich
with symbolism but where will the real
substance be done about whether North
Korea will disarm its nuclear program
they will be done in the Trump Kim
summit not in this summit this summit
was all aspirations South Korea can't
end the Korean War South Korea can't yet
North Korea to denuclearize only the
United States and the United Nations can
do that so the real work has yet to come
but president Trump has called in the
past for a complete denuclearization is
that going to happen so the next summit
the Kim Trump summit is going to be a
lot harder than this one because both
countries are coming at it with very
different expectations North Korea's
expectation is we are now a nuclear
weapons state treat us like one we're
willing to negotiate limits to our
program to get rid of the sanctions
we're coming at it from the perspective
of we have strangled you with sanctions
now give up your program and then we'll
be willing to get rid of them so the the
really hard work the really tough work
is yet to come
do we have an assessment Mike of what
has gotten them to the table is it the
president saying being very strong as he
says on military or is it the sanctions
is it their the fact that they can't get
energy I think one of the really
interesting differences here is that
both side both the United States and
North Korea are coming to the table for
different reasons and both sides are
misreading the other side we think that
we've brought North Korea to the table
by putting our arms around their neck
and squeezing with sanctions North Korea
is coming to the table because they
think they are now a nuclear weapons
State and they're dragging us to the
table because we are afraid of them in
that status
what okay is there a middle place short
of mothballing the entire North Korean
nuclear program that the US could get to
that would allow an agreement but
wouldn't get all the way to mothball
again so this is the fundamental policy
question that the Trump administration
is going to have to deal with right are
we going to continue to push for full
denuclearization we
I don't believe is possible or are we
gonna settle somewhere in the middle
with limits on the program limits on the
number of weapons limits on the number
of missiles limits on the range of those
missiles whatever the reasons to get us
here the optics sure look pretty good
this morning is this a feather in the
cap for Donald Trump so I think the
president deserves credit for getting us
this far no president has put as much
pressure on North Korea as Donald Trump
has and and that's a good thing I think
that the outcome of last night's summit
is not surprising both North Korea and
South Korea desperately want the Kim
Trump summit to happen right and they
wanted they wanted their talks to be
extraordinarily positive yeah and Trump
and president moon had said from a long
time ago they want to have these
bilateral talks that need a knee and it
is happening it is happening
thank you that to you Becca when you did
the interview well to be continued for
sure effect we'll see a little bit later
on anywhere